this is Kiki's pizza delivery service 10
points just for that title I'm very
disappointed there was not a sarcastic
app with the voice of Phil Hartman
though get me to say okay I think what
says nudie can in this episode surreal
enough this is a first of all it's more
Nightmare on Elm Street then first of
all mmm pizza tonight between this and
the last episode I freaking want pizza
really bad um but yes there's an episode
where a Kiki is picking up her sisters
shift as a pizza delivery girl and she's
having these nightmares well it looks
like Steven can go into her dream which
lets contact him with Lars I think
didn't go into his dreams or you just
before he took over the money or
whatever so it's something it involved
Lars I have blocked it from my memory so
it's something he can do and she has
this reoccurring dream so he always
comes in to try and help her out but
weirdly enough he's not getting sleep I
guess it's not REM sleep or something
it's not hi explained but he's dreaming
yeah I don't worry yeah I don't really
know how that works but it's like work
maybe I don't know I guess you don't
dream a hundred percent of the time that
you're asleep well tell you what comes
in fits and burst yet them and actually
go into other people's dreams so we'll
just assume if you could do that it's a
Star Trek episode night terrors where I
I'm just saying like they big weren't
dreaming so they were all going nuts so
in this case uh so he finally goes and
tries to Bobby's gonna keep talking over
you yeah I don't care
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah below he goes
and
you know get your out of this whole
predicament of everything but finally
love doing this over and over it why are
you describing the flow maybe they have
it it's a recap okay why would they be
watching this if they haven't seen it
well maybe I'll preview from my girl
maybe I haven't seen it in a while it
was just I need to be reminded ace your
fucking spoiler not swelling I remind
why do you hate them I remind night I
love them I love you all
you're amazing he's an asshole you're
amazing okay don't forget it love you
he's an asshole you're really gonna buy
that horseshit mm-hmm mission
accomplished god damn it
all right so if I said you had to
confront something here because you keep
having these nightmares it turns out she
just needs to tell her sister that she
you know is getting away for personal
life and you know she's no she's doing
doing a good thing
but he's gonna owe them and she does
then things are gonna boss you have done
uh-huh and it was a complete waste tie
it in to what we were talking about what
were you telling email I forget because
you're going oh um heõs like we've had 2
O 3 now episodes they were kind of like
okay not important episodes but out of
the three and the three of them I like
this one and you can tell me I don't
know how because we do things like oh
yeah nothing else down here
uh no but this episode I thought was
actually a lot of fun I thought it was a
good idea it was creative um I liked the
lesson at the end I think that's a good
lesson uh because it's not like a huge
thing but it's something that and it was
the Mohegan Pam it was the most
interesting looking definitely of the
past there is in I didn't think the past
who had anything really interesting
going on um I mean very cute game
visually but this one with the dream
world I thought it was really good and I
said why wasn't it called a nightmare
inbred street or something because you
have a girl named Kiki and she's
delivering pizzas you had you had but it
was more about nightmares and dreams and
yeah was asthma
about delivery but he kind of was you
shame Miyazaki sounds and sexist I don't
know I
why is incest in Japan it's all about
champions you shame yourself and your
ancestors oh then you throw yourself on
your sword no I like this idea of him
going in and like helping out with the
dreams I am sure other ideas have done
that before but I just I still like it's
a good idea and I do I don't I'm not
sure I get it why he can't sleep in his
own dreams but metaphor for something
I'm sure well I think they just need
something that's fine like okay he can't
do this anymore but I guess I can ties
in because like how she can't do it
anymore it's having a toll on her it's
kinda like he can't do anymore cuz it's
having a toll on him so it's sort of you
know comes full circle yes I would have
had it where he's kind of going that's
like the dream worlds invading like his
and a row because he's just dreaming too
much knows imaginations run wild and um
but I don't I don't know it was a good
episode I I concur we really need to go
grab a pizza yeah god um cuz this
episode and the last one um but this one
more my favorite is when they went up in
it cuz you're just like cuz I'm like my
really want a pizza when he's sardine
pizza he's like oh you were like I know
right and then when it cut to their
dream world it's just like alright yeah
pizza tonight you were just like oh my
god come on so not fair but yeah I gotta
get pizza tonight I have no choice
um and I really like the message of that
because I feel like that something like
it is definitely smaller but I feel like
this one does kind of show like the toll
it can have I mean that can't stop
getting into your dreams and that you're
you know not getting sleep and
everything else I can count affect your
you know when you're awake um but on top
of that just sometimes you know when
stress stress ability just doing so many
nice things you know it can it can have
an effect on you and then you can start
to be you know a little mean cuz you're
not quite
you know the time that you need and
stuff so uh I really like I think that's
a nice like it's a smaller thing but
it's something that's good to address I
think it's good to address you know uh
when you're younger to you know it's
okay to say you need me time match even
starts off with Steven having me time
you know with like he's setting up the
nice played in the flower that you think
it's a date and it's just him eating a
pizza like that's it that's how I eat
pizza
know if bread like a Bobby my Laurel
arrangement for pizza eating at first I
thought like he was gonna try and like
date Kiki which I'm just like oh we
don't like a gravity falls thing all
over again with like the the older girl
and stuff it's like no he just really
likes having it Pizza alone um so uh
yeah I feel like that it all kind of
tied together in a good way I thought
this was a pretty smart funny creative
episode um even though nothing huge but
you know it was good oh and hey uh no
Ronaldo no Ronaldo no Lars no Lars that
automatically you're starting off at at
least a c-plus yeah give you if you
eliminate those two then your base
starting point as a c-plus I I hope yeah
I'm sorry
if both of them are in it you were
starting off at an F - and it's a long
climb are you sound sure the act was
very nice where we came up with the
characters very nice and everything I
just can't stand the character sorry
just came to it um but uh do you think
there's some drinking game now any time
I mentioned we're not very long shot oh
I do it I had to be drunk to get through
even all of us oh no I just do it with
no I mean drinking game listening to our
v1 song yeah I would totally I'm a
hearing us talk about Rihanna they need
you watch on watching over for um no
just listen to us like anytime they
mentioned them that you could die though
you really were running the bed probably
the exact every other episode I feel
like we mention our hatred for those
characters so yeah that's about it
uh Matt you know I think we usually say
we do like five a week or something like
that so uh sorry we haven't gotten to
like the real the real shit going down
yet
you know everybody were told on that
she's oh my god as industry we watch him
like round back at it anywhere right so
uh yeah hopefully the next one gets a
little bit more intensive not uh yeah
well just see you the next one either
like that we'll just skip it
uh-huh uh-huh